hi I'm Evan Carmichael and in today's
video I wanted to answer a question for
one of my readers the mighty Gilda I
hope I pronounced that properly she is a
mother and an entrepreneur and is having
a hard time balancing her career and her
family life as well and is wondering if
I could give her some advice so you are
not alone time management is one of the
biggest issues that entrepreneurs are
facing and trying to figure out what the
focus on with the business and have it
all balance out with with the work life
as well so the things that I would try
to remind you of things to focus on is
look at the things that you can do that
give the most of value to your customers
where you can have the biggest impact we
can be the most helpful and try to focus
on those things those things that you're
really good at that you know can help a
lot of people or really help your target
customer is that some unique value that
you can bring so you want to really make
sure you're spending time doing that and
everything else we want to slowly
eliminate delegate and automate away so
that you know you have time to focus on
what you're really good at so quickly
about my story and I was not that great
when I first started up as well with
time management and the first part was
illuminating so look at all the things
that you're doing that you might think
got a lot of value but don't really a
good story for me was I used to take
minute notes so we had we had meetings I
would always take notes of the minute so
what we talked about a summary of the
conversation I'm taking a lot of time to
make these minutes and then I send it
off to people and figured all this is
great value that I'm adding on top and
it turned out
people didn't really care about my my
minute notes so I was spend all this
time doing something that wasn't really
value-add so I eliminated it and there's
a lot of other things you can probably
eliminate from your day to day that
probably isn't that useful or that
valuable the next step we want to look
at is automated so what are some of the
tasks that you do that you can automate
to make your life a lot easier
great story for me was using accounting
software it's so easy to do my annual
and quarterly books just download all my
statements in my accounting software
takes me 20 minutes every quarter and
I'm done so look and technology is a way
to automate some of the things that
you're doing that might be really
time-consuming that hopefully you can
take off the plate and automate over to
technology the last part is delegating
and you want to make sure you go in that
order where you're eliminating first
then you're automating and then you're
delegating his delegating is likely
gonna be the most expensive part and
that's what you're giving tasks to other
people and it doesn't have to start off
doing full time you hire somebody and
cost you a lot of money and you know you
start going bankrupt but if you can hire
somebody even for a short amount of time
the first person I hired was for one
hour a day and you would do some data
entry for me and that saved me one hour
a day and so now I had an hour to focus
on growing my business so think about
some of the tasks you can do that you
can delegate away as well they're great
services now like oDesk and Elance we've
been fine people may not work you know
close to you but can be in different
countries and spread out and can do a
lot of tenacity with a pretty good wages
and that can really help you grow your
business and help you focus on some of
the things that you're really good ok so
focus on what your your strengths are
we've not the most value be the most
helpful to your customers then look at
how
can eliminate automate and delegate
everything else away and hopefully they
don't give you the stepping stones you
need to build a successful business I
hope that helps if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up I'd also love
to hear your thoughts and feedback if
you want to leave a comment below and
stay tuned for the next episode
you